à combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
pâte à puch qu'il ne faut trop échos
notez bien sur vos droits drm mois dort
pas
attention il vous manque un
[Musique]
pour qu'elle monte dans les magasins
harrods est morte de fatigue pas tant
que science po paris
c'est pas possible tout le monde doit
faire ses courses soi-même dans itunes
pour mendy bon à l'orangé tout ça dans
la cuisine bien pata zif j'étais à
portée des bonds partout
[Musique]
ouah
humana qu'est ce que tu as rien aulas
quoi tu as mangé tous les bonbons
pas tout à fait graves voies il en reste
un
et maintenant tu as mal aux dents alors
ne te plains pas il a une dent qui doit
tomber at heart on ne peut pas laisser
comme ça il faut faire quelque chose
oui mais quoi nous avons tout essayé
[Musique]
bon niveau qu'ils à niveau pilule de lui
en fait de l'effet il faut donc arraché
la dent malade je veux paris veut pas je
veux pas avec douceur dans la
décontraction et si je te l'enlève
tu pourras manger tous les bonbons que
tu voudras tous les bonbons presque et
tu m'acheter un grand sac de pâtes de
fruits oui bon d'accord allait bien avec
moi je vais prendre mes petits
instruments
[Musique]
non
elle protège instruments
[Musique]
enfin
non
dans
[Musique]
avant
qu'est ce qui se passe là dedans on
pleure on crie c'est la grande panique
enfin ce move en main se devant de
grosses sommes
pour petit je prends ça remet à si je
n'étais pas là très bien si tu préfères
te faire soigner par monsieur bougon
mais ne viens pas te plaindre après pas
attendu que l'histoire
vous ne pensez pas que le dentiste vous
tombez bien vous savez au régiment c'est
moi tu arracher toutes les gares dans
des manifs il
duffy
[Musique]
pas de crête pas de souffrance ses
propres vite et bien fait je vais ouvrir
la porte d'un geste sec et la dombes
viendra tout seul
j'ai fait ça plus de 500 fois j'ai vu
voler des râteliers en entier ah c'était
le bon temps
enfin nous attendrit sont pas très peu
de buts
alors on y va
allô allô monsieur dentiste combien
croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux papas pêche
ne faut trop époque notez bien sur vos
droits
by claude attention il en manque un
[Musique]